when I heard that the high school or
high school musical version had never
staged a production of High School
Musical the musical I was shocked
inspired and triggered as millennial
auditions are after school I've seen the
original movie 37 times and the first 15
minutes of those sequels it would be
insane to think I might actually have a
shot at playing Gabriella I know we're
not a couple anymore it was my idea to
take a pause I didn't want to take a
pause I can't believe it she's dating
each a husband this is a nightmare
I won't audition for Gabriella Ryan
right I think you'd rather play sure pay
that is so fresh a bomb that we don't
have any competition here she has to see
me in a whole new light I'm auditioning
for this thing tomorrow and nothing is
gonna stop me the cast list is posted we
have our Gabriella and our Troy buckle
up Wildcats it's about to get real
I basically have zero chill about this
right half
[Music]
what are you doing here she really cared
about me you but somebody who wants to
play this part play
you all walked in here as strangers but
after today you're a family I believe
nos
[Music]
[Applause]
excuse me is there somewhere you're
supposed to be Broadway
you